PROFESSOR: There are
two generalizations
of the bijection rule
and the product rule that
come up all the time and
play an essential role
in the repertoire
of any counter.
So let's look at those.
The first of these
is a generalization
of the product rule.
And let's see an instance
where it comes up.
Suppose I wanted to count
the number of lineups
of five students in the class.
So if I let S be the number
of students, and let's say,
for the afternoon
session S is 91, then
the number of lineups of
five students-- if I use
the ordinary product
rule, I would
get-- I'm talking about
S to the fifth, that is,
sequences of length
five of elements of S.
And so the product
rule would say,
take 91 to the
fifth as the number
of lineups of five students.
And that would be correct if the
same student could appear twice
in line, but that,
of course, isn't
possible with real students.
So the lineups have no repeats.
And what we're really
counting is the number
of those sequences of
length five of students
with no repeats.
And the generalized
product rule tells
you quite straightforwardly
how to count those.
Namely, there are 91 ways
to choose the first student
among the 91.
And whichever first
student you've chosen,
that leaves 90 other students
you could choose to be second.
And once you've chosen
the first two, that
leaves 89 students you
could choose for the third,
and 88 for the fourth,
and 87 for the fifth.
And the formula then is 91
times 90 times 89, 88, 87,
for the number of sequences
of distinct students
of length five.
Now, one nice way to
express the 91 down
to 87, in terms of factorials,
is its 91 factorial,
which is the product
from 1 to 91,
and divided by the
product from 1 to 86,
which cancels out the first
86 terms in 91 factorial,
leaving me with exactly
87 through 91 product.
So the second rule is a sort
of obvious generalization
of the bijectional, but I'm
getting ahead of myself.
Let's state the generalized
product rule in general.
So if we let Q be a set
of length-k sequences
with the following
property, there
are n1 possible first elements
among these length-k sequences.
And for every one of the
first possible elements,
if you look at the
number of tuples
with what the second possible
coordinates for a given
first coordinate,
it's always n2.
And likewise, if you
look at the number
of possible third coordinates
given the first two, it's n3
and it's uniform no matter
what the first two are.
Then if you have this
kind of a set up,
which is exactly what happens
when you're picking one student
after another and
they can't compete,
you discover that the
length-k sequences with n1 ,
first possible choices, n2,
second possible choices,
down through nk, k-th possible
choices is n1 through nk.
So that's the statement
of the generalized product
rule in the magenta box.
Now, we come to the generalized
bijection rule, which
is called the division rule.
And a simple, memorable
way to illustrate
is if you wanted to count the
number of students in class
6.042, you could count the
number of students fingers
and divide by 10.
Now, it's probably harder to
count fingers than students,
so this is not meant
as a practical method.
But it illustrates a basic
and straightforward idea.
Of course, it's
implicitly assuming
that we don't have any
instances of amputations
or polydactylism, and that,
in fact, every student
has exactly 10 fingers.
OK, so in general,
the division rule
can be stated this
way, if I have
a total function from a set A to
a set B, domain A, co-domain B,
and this mapping is k-to-1,
then the cardinality of A
is simply k times the
cardinality of B. So k-to-1
means that exactly k A
elements hit each B element.
Another way to say it is that
there are exactly k arrows
into every element of B. So
then the number of arrows
is simply k times B. And if
you have a total function on A,
the number of arrows is
equal to the size of A,
and that's where
we get the formula.
OK.
And that's the generalized
bijection rule.
Let's apply it in
a crucial example
that is absolutely basic and
we'll be using repeatedly.
Suppose that I want to know how
many possible subsets of size
four are there from the
numbers 1 through 13?
So I have 13 possible
numbers that I can choose.
I want to pick out
any four of them
and I want to know how many
ways are there to do that.
And we'll do that by finding
a mapping from things
we know how to count to
these particular subsets.
So what we know how
to count is if I
let A be the set of all
permutations of 1 through 13,
then I know that the size of A
is 13 factorial because there's
13 choices for the first
element of the permutation, 12
for the second, down
to one for the 13th.
And let's let B be this
object that I want to count,
namely, the set of size four
subsets of 1 through 13.
And I want to find
a mapping from A
that I know how to count
to B that I don't yet
know how to count,
but in a way where
I can figure out that
it's k-to-1 for a k
that I can also count.
How do I do that?
Well, let's take an
arbitrary permutation of A,
that is to say, a
sequence of the elements
of A in some order-- call
them a1, a2, through a13.
So these numbers a1 through a13
are those numbers 1 through 13
in some unknown order.
And I'm going to map
a permutation of A,
like this, to its
first four elements.
Just take the first four
elements of the permutation
and map them to
the set consisting
of those four elements.
Now, since this
is a permutation,
these elements
are all different,
so I really do get a set of
four different things here,
a1, a2, and a3.
And a4 is supposed
to be different.
This gives me a very
well-defined total function
from a permutation of 13
numbers to set of its first four
elements.
And now what we want to know is
what kind of a mapping is this?
And I'm going to argue that
it's k-to-1 for a k that's
not very hard to count.
So when I look at
what other things map
to the set a1, a2, a3, a4,
we mapped a permutation
to its first four elements.
And if we've got a1 through a4
as the set, what other things
map to that set a1, a2, a3, a4?
Well, the answer
is any permutation
with the same first four
elements, but possibly
in a different order,
because we're just
going to take the
first four in sequence
and map them to the set
of those first four.
The order in which the
first four doesn't matter.
OK?
And likewise, the order of
the remaining nine elements,
5 through 13, also
doesn't matter.
Whatever they are, if I have
a given set of four elements
to start, no matter what
the remaining 9 are,
they're going to map to the
same subset of four elements.
So there are 4
factorial possible ways
that the first four
elements can be permuted.
And there are 9 factorial
ways that the last nine
elements can be permuted.
And every one of these goes to
the same set of four elements,
a1 through a4.
And those are the only
ones that go there.
And so what we've figured
out is that the mapping
of these kind of sequences with
the given four elements first
in some order and
the remaining nine
elements in some other
order is 4 factorial times 9
factorial-to-1.
There are 4 factorial times
9 factorial permutations
that map to any given
set of four elements.
And that means that by
applying the division rule,
I've discovered that the
size of A, which I know
is 13 factorial,
is equal to that k
of the k-to-1 of 4 factorial
times 9 factorial times
the size of B.
B is the subsets of size four
that I'm trying to count.
And so what I get is
that the size of B
is simply 13 factorial
divided by that k, 4
factorial 9 factorial, 13
factorial over 4 factorial
9 factorial.
And this number
comes up so often
that it has this
special notation called
binomial coefficient notation,
which we read as 13 choose 4.
In general, if I
have an n element set
and I'm going to choose a subset
of m of them-- generalizing
this argument because
the 4 and the 9
and the 13 were
completely arbitrary
and the argument
works in general--
is that the number of ways
to choose a set of m elements
among n is n choose m.
And the definition
of n choose m is
n factorial over
the m factorial ways
to permute the first m elements
and the n minus m factorial
ways to permute the
remaining n minus m elements.
And again, that notation,
the binomial coefficient,
is called n over
m is n choose m.
This is an absolutely
fundamental formula
that you need to remember
because we will be using it
constantly and repeatedly.